Warframe devs announced a brand new game
Xbox and Activision Blizzard's deal is
getting closer to wrapping up and Game
Pass Game Pass Game Pass
Warframe developer digital extremes has
announced a new game called Soul frame a
free-to-play action hybrid MMORPG that
is now in early development in a
statement the game's creative director
Jeff Crooks said quote our team is
really interested in this idea of Nature
and Humanity colliding and we'll be
exploring a lot of these themes through
our own lens while playing with ideas of
restoration and exploration digital
extreme said it will develop Soul frame
alongside the community as part of a
quote transparent collaborative and
iterative process development on
Warframe will continue as other members
of the team switch to Soul frame at
tenocon digital extreme shared more
footage of the open world story
expansion and announced a new story
called Veil breaker it's still very
early days for soul frame and there is
no word yet on platforms or release date
so while you wait for soulframe why not
dig into some new game pass editions
July 19th AKA tomorrow sees the arrival
of three more games beginning with the
day one new release as dusk Falls for
console cloud and PC this is an
interactive drama and the debut title
from developer interior night a team
founded by Quantic dream veterans also
arriving on July 19th is sins of a solar
Empire Rebellion along with ubisoft's
Watchdogs 2 for console cloud and PC and
other Microsoft news the company's
acquisition of Activision Blizzard has
gotten even closer to being a done deal
in March the FTC asked for more
information from Activision Blizzard and
Microsoft to further review the
acquisition deal after the additional
information is reviewed the FTC will
have 30 days to challenge the
acquisition if not the deal can continue
as planned we now know thanks to VGC
that Microsoft has provided the FTC with
the information it was looking for
however it's unclear if Activision
Blizzard has yet provided the FTC with
the proper information if not then the
30 days to challenge the acquisition
will be put on hold until after division
blizzard shares the requested
information once the FTC closes the
investigation the deal will be one step
closer to being finalized and now let's
talk about Star Wars Hunters the
upcoming team-based combat game for
switch and mobile that won't be
launching on schedule publisher Zenga
announced today that the game is being
delayed worldwide to 2023 so the studio
can quote meet the high expectations of
fans and the developers themselves
Hunters had a soft launch on mobile
already and Zenga thanked fans for their
feedback that the studio is using to
help the game become quote the best it
can be are you excited at all for
hunters do you work for the FTC let me
know all of that in the comments below
and I'll see you tomorrow